you've got the seventy sixers before we
talk about how the team is doing you
just did a deal with stubhub how does
this help the team how does it help fans
because you need people to want to go to
those games sure do advance our fans who
are amazing want three things they want
safe they want convenient and they want
easy and so what this does is put all
the tickets in one place so you're five
klicks away from buying it actually
blends the primary and secondary market
so you don't have to go chasing go to
our site and then go to stubhub site to
buy so it's a complete a revolutionary
change for the family why aren't other
teams doing this then there's been a lot
of push back in terms of engaging the
secondary market not so much anymore I
mean I think you know and I don't know
why teams wouldn't do this I mean
anytime you can help make it easier for
fans to buy I think that's an easy one
the other thing that we get here is day
to day to data and so the more we know
about our fans so it's not just knowing
who they are and who buys but what they
buy and what the preferences are and
then it's pretty easy to now segment
them and then direct market to them for
a game that might make sense all right
well let's talk about how to get them in
those seats people talk about the value
of big data but you need a team that
wins the top five teams in the NBA are
worth four times the amount of the
bottom five teams and clearly you see
players wanting to go to those marquee
teams marquee markets put you in a
really tough position what do you do
well we're going to build a winning team
that's that's our plan as the process
and the good news is is as we've talked
about several times the value these
franchises just keeps going up and up
and up and when you're in a market like
Philadelphia we think we're very well
positioned in terms of a young talent on
the court specifically we've got to
really really good young players they're
both in the rising stars game Nerlens
Noel and Jahlil Okafor we've got our
pick we might have the Lakers pick top
three protected we have Miami's
first-round pick and Oklahoma City's
first round pick so we're pretty
positioned to get very good in very
quickly this is a big summer for us why
build a big practice center in Camden
New Jersey how does that help with a
seventy Sixers experience we're just
coming off the super bowl in San
Francisco with a new stadium where it is
all about technology if you don't have a
stadium that embraces the new world of
technology and social media you got
nothing
well for us we're tenants in
Philadelphia and so we work with comcast
as a partner and they're terrific for
that arena there in terms of why we
building Camden it's your home state
first of all it is secondly new home
town though no it's not but New Jersey
is an incredible does an incredible job
of providing economic incentives for
businesses to build and we got a chance
to build on the waterfront help
redevelop a city on the rise Camden and
it's 125,000 square feet most
technologically advanced most beautiful
most spectacular and the largest
training facility in the world but it's
a city on the rise maybe look at global
market Scott we are in a sell-off the US
economy is struggling it's one of the
reasons you see candidates like Bernie
Sanders and Donald Trump do so well
having a big investment in a high-risk
city might not have seemed so high-risk
a year ago but has the landscape change
do you really want to be in Camden we do
you know we're in in areas where we
think we can make a difference so we
spend time as you know the Prudential
Center in Newark New Jersey and I think
it's been proven time and time again
that when you build an arena or your
invest in a community in need and you
reach out the community and develop
programs to lift up and help the city it
has a pretty impactful change a great
example that would be in Washington DC
where you drop that arena right in the
middle of a very depressed area you go
there now if you went there 10 years ago
it looks very different from way it
looks now that's what we intend to do
well then take big data and help us
overlay what that looks like what the
economy looks like every day we talk
about the value of the consumer where
they're spending money their disposable
income how healthy they are well more
and more consumers more more people
we're facing lower wages even though
unemployment is it a good place people
aren't spending given the data you have
what does the economy look like in your
mind when you create budgets
surprisingly I mean with a team that
struggled over the last 3 years our
business continues to go up both and the
corporate level and sponsorship spending
is almost tripled in the last three
years and our season ticket base has
doubled in the last three years with it
with a team that struggled so at least
from our perspective I think the passion
points are beating the pocketbooks are
you concerned that you could see that
slowed down because we have had a bull
run in the markets for the last few
years and now if things turn
corporations stop spending disposable
income
ends up what does that mean for you
there's certainly some risk because it's
discretionary spending fans don't have
to buy Sixers tickets or devils tickets
or tickets to go see Bruce at the
prudential center they don't have to but
these are the passion like but it's a
passion like you will give something
else up to go see Andrew Don your
favorite team I think we have an
advantage you do it's not a refrigerator
like you can put your refrigerator off
but this is this is something that's
going to happen once and you want to be
a part of it what an incredible
experience people come there it's like a
religious experience you come to our
games when we hear that the value of
live events is only going up does that
mean you have to deliver a whole lot
more absolutely like what I mean well
you know from off so you if you came to
our game a big VIP like yourself you
would walk in you'd have the coach would
address it before the game so if 20
people the coach specifically speaks to
you before the game 20 on one you might
go sit in courtside seats and watch
joelle and bead shoot around you might
get a locker room tour we're doing we're
getting you behind the scenes in places
you couldn't otherwise get we walk you
out on the court and be your picture on
the court so we do our whole VIP
experience has been completely changed
and making a huge difference